bonjour je m'appelle faire et je vais
être papa c'est quoi quand vous regardez
la tâche qu'est ce qui vous surprend le
plus et pourquoi moi j'ai offert une
très belle question c'est tout ce qui
est le plus surprenant
d'abord la terre est extrêmement belle
mais ça c'est pas surprenant je le
savais ce qui me surprend le plus c'est
à quel point la majorité de la terre est
pas vraiment habitable pour les êtres
humains
on croit que la terre est très grosse
c'est vrai qu'elle est grosse mais la
plupart de la terre d'abord c'est des
océans et la partie qui est pas un océan
qui pourrait submerger
c'est surtout des déserts où des
montagnes alors les endroits sur terre
où les êtres humains peut vivre c'est
vraiment une petite fraction de la
planète est à peu près on peut voir la
toute petite couche de l'atmosphère dans
lequel nous survivons dans le vide de
l'espace
et ça me frappe à quel point à chaque
fois la bulle dans lequel les êtres
humains vivent est minuscule et fragile
et nous devons en prendre bien soin ou
non aux jo intraday la vérendrye et moi
je veux te poser une question pouvez
vous voir des désastres naturels de la
station spatiale
oui on peut voir des désastres
effectivement par exemple on peut voir
des inondations très facilement 6 et des
grandes inondations j'en ai vu la
semaine dernière en amérique du sud
on peut voir que les rivières sont ont
débordé de leur lit
on peut voir les éruptions volcaniques
ou si on peut voir la fumée qui sort des
volcans en éruption
ça c'est le diraient les désastres des
plus grands qu'on peut voir depuis
l'espace je suis ni d'être honnête avec
soi à quoi ressemblent les ouragans et
les tempêtes de l'espace
bonjour nive alors un ouragan vue de
l'espace c'est comme un immense
tourbillon ce comme un nuage en forme de
tourbillon blanc lacs au centre un trou
et le trou c'est la dépression centrale
là où le vent elle est le plus fort et
ça c'est les ouragans et on peut voir
les tempêtes skis et ski le plus beau
c'est voir les éclairs des tempêtes la
nuit quand on vole la nuit au dessus
d'une tempête c'est comme s'il y avait
des flashs qui apparaissent un peu
partout
c'est vraiment vraiment extraordinaires
mambo de voir ça on voit les nuages au
dessus de nous qui sont aux blancs et de
temps en temps pour des éclairs de
lumière qui apparaissent à l'intérieur
des nuages
bonjour j'aimerais juste de l'école
catholique la vérendrye et ma question
pour vous est-ce que vous pouvez voir
les lumières des grandes villes de la
station spatiale
un jour j'ai dit oui c'est très facile
la nuit on voit toutes les villes et
c'est d'ailleurs c'est très intéressant
parce que durant le jour c'est difficile
de voir l'impact de l'être humain sur la
terre c'est plus la nuit c'est très
facile à cause des lumières partout
surtout quand on vole au dessus de
l'endroit comme l'amérique ou l'europe
ou l'asie on voit des lumières toutes
les villes on les voit c'est très facile
et d'ailleurs je m'amuse à essayer de
deviner les filets ville d'après la
forme qu'on peut voir de leurs lumières
bonjour ceci étant dû connaître à
bassecourt pouvait vous voir encore
murale de chine de la station spatiale
ou est-ce que ça c'est justement à une
très bonne question je me suis posé la
même question et j'ai essayé de la voir
la muraille puis non on peut pas la voir
moi je n'ai pas été capable en tout cas
je pense que c'est parce que la muraille
elle n'est pas continue c'est juste
c'est comme des petits morceaux et l'ont
jamais terminée et on fait des petits
morceaux alors c'est comme une ligne
pointillée ça c'est difficile d'avoir de
l'espace moi je n'ai pas réussi à voir
et ma question est est ce qu'on peut
voir un grand changement sur la planète
ronde l'été l'hiver
oui tristan très facile d'acoz de la
neige est surtout impressionnant la nuit
la pleine lune et lorsque c'est la
pleine lune durant la nuit on voit la
neige qui est éclairée en blanc à la
terre toute la terre brille blanche même
la nuit c'est vraiment fantastique
la vérendrye je me demandais si vous
pouvez voir l'impact des changements
climatiques ou la pollution de l'espace
comme le smag au dos il a péché bonjour
jade
oui on peut voir on peut voir un espèce
de dalles au dessus des plus grandes
villes car le maillot du smag on peut
voir ou ce qu'on peut voir aussi pour
les changements climatiques on peut
comparer les glaciers qu'on voit dans
les montagnes avec des photographies
anciennes des glaciers de même là si on
peut voir qu'ils ont beaucoup de l'acier
ou diminuer énormément à cause du
réchauffement climatique à cause des
changements climatiques sa c2 et faire
qu'on peut voir assez facilement
je m'appelle clara et g20
l'exploit est ce que vous pouvez devenir
devenir la météo juste en regardant la
faire je peux voir le temps qui fait
maintenant mais je suis pas très bon
pour deviner le temps qu'il va faire
demain on peut voir évidemment peut-être
s'il ya des orages qui s'en viennent
dans un pays un peu comme quand tu vois
quand tu écoutes la météo aux nouvelles
il ya des grandes cartes là où on voit
le on voit les nuages qui se déplacent
ça c'est des prédictions
alors on peut s'amuser à se faire la
même chose mais c'est très difficile
donc même vu de l'espace est difficile
de prévoir la météo